Menschen, die wild umherrennen,
zerstörte Städte
und eine waghalsige Rettungsmission:
Ein neuer Katastrophenfilm
ist am Start:
"Moonfall"
aus der Feder von Roland Emmerich.
Bleibt wachsam,
meine Brüder und Schwestern.
Vom Inhalt weiß ich noch nicht viel.
Aber den Titel
dürfen wir wohl wörtlich nehmen.
Im Laufe des Films rückt der Mond
der Erde extrem auf die Pelle.
Und wir klären heute:
Was würde passieren,
wenn der Mond auf uns zukommt?
# I see the bad moon arising.
# I see trouble on the way.
Hallo, zusammen.
In der Folge zum Netflix-Hit
"Don't look up" besprachen wir,
wie man einen Asteroiden-Einschlag
auf der Erde verhindern könnte.
Der Mond ist ein anderes Kaliber.
Der ist ein paar hundertmal größer
und deshalb auch viel schwerer.
Man könnte ihn
nicht einfach ablenken.
Wir kennen bisher
nur die Trailer des Films.
Wir haben noch keine Ahnung,
ob Aliens, Raumstationen
oder mysteriöse Kräfte
eine Rolle spielen.
Wir schauen uns unseren Mond an.
Und klären, was uns drohen würde,
wenn der sich auf Kollisionskurs
mit unserem Planeten befinden würde.
Nicht nur die Erde wäre am Arsch.
Aktuell ist der Mond genau dort,
wo er sein soll:
beruhigende 385.000 km entfernt.
Auf einer fast exakten Kreisbahn
düst er um unseren Planeten.
Mit einer Geschwindigkeit
von einem Kilometer pro Sekunde.
Also etwa 3.500 km/h.
Diese Geschwindigkeit würde
ihn direkt an uns vorbeischießen.
Wäre da nicht die Gravitation,
also die Schwerkraft der Erde.
Die wirkt so stark auf den Mond,
dass er immer wieder
an die Erde herangezogen wird.
Dadurch ergibt sich
ein stabiler Orbit.
Was ich nicht wusste:
Von außen betrachtet,
dreht sich der Mond
nicht um den Erdmittelpunkt.
Sondern das gesamte Erde-Mond-System
bewegt sich
um diesen gemeinsamen Schwerpunkt.
Das ist nicht der Erdmittelpunkt.
Denn die Anziehungskraft des Mondes
zieht diesen Drehpunkt nach außen.
Das bedeutet auch:
Wenn es im Erde-Mond-System
nur die Schwerkraft geben würde,
würde die dafür sorgen,
dass sie sich aufeinander zu bewegen.
Und ineinander stürzen.
Aber zum Glück bewegt sich der Mond.
Seine Fliehkraft wirkt
der Erdanziehungskraft entgegen.
In der Realität ist es sogar so,
dass sich der Mond Stück für Stück
von der Erde weg bewegt.
Und zwar jedes Jahr um 3,8 cm.
Wie genau das funktioniert,
erklärt uns eine Physikern,
die sich mit dem Weltall auskennt.
Sie ist Moderatorin beim DLR.
Hey, Sina.
Der Grund für die Flucht des Mondes
ist die Gezeitenkraft.
Also die Kraft, die auf der Erde
für Ebbe und Flut sorgt.
Gezeitenkräfte ergeben sich daraus,
dass die Schwerkraft eines Körpers
mit dem Abstand abnimmt.
Die wirkt auf andere Körper
also nicht komplett gleichmäßig.
Der Mond zieht stärker
an der ihm zugewandten Erdseite
als auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite
dahinter.
Dadurch verformt er die Erde
ein bisschen.
Wir merken das nicht,
weil wir draufstehen
auf der verformten Oberfläche.
Aber wir merken es
an den Wassermassen.
Die Gezeitenkraft verformt
die Wassermassen unserer Erde.
Dann bilden sich Flutberge.
Aber die Erde dreht sich
unter den Flutbergen weiter.
Dadurch verschiebt sie die Flutberge
mit ihrer Rotation.
Jetzt passieren 2 Sachen:
Der Mond versucht,
diese Flutberge zurückzuziehen.
Aber die Flutberge hängen durch
Reibungskräfte an der Erdoberfläche.
Diese Reibung sorgt dafür,
dass sich die Rotation der Erde
verlangsamt.
Und die verschobenen Flutberge
ziehen wiederum am Mond.
Sodass deren Schwerkraft
vor dem Mond stärker wird
als hinter dem Mond.
Durch dieses Ungleichgewicht
wird der Mond beschleunigt.
Wenn er schneller wird,
wird seine Fliehkraft größer.
Das Wort deutet es schon an:
Der Mond flieht immer
ein Stücken mehr von der Erde.
Das sind pro Jahr 3,8 cm.
Der Mond war also vor 30 Jahren
über einen Meter näher an der Erde.
Machen wir einen Contest.
Wer von uns hat den Mond
am nächsten erlebt?
Holt einen Taschenrechner,
tippt euer Alter ein
und multipliziert mit 3,8.
Schreibt in die Kommentare,
wie viele Zentimeter
der Mond bei eurer Geburt
näher an der Erde war.
Ich brauche deine Hilfe.
Sag ja, Brian.
Für den Spaß an Gedankenspielen:
Gehen wir mal davon aus,
dass der Mond
der Erde wirklich näher kommt.
Roland Emmerich
hat eine Vorstellung davon,
was passieren würde.
Die Evakuierung der Westküste
wurde soeben angeordnet.
Womit müssten wir wirklich rechnen?
Um die Erde
muss man sich weniger Sorgen machen
als um den Mond selbst.
Wir sprachen darüber,
wie die Gezeitenkraft
die Erde verformt.
Und die Wassermassen auf der Erde.
Das geht auch andersherum.
Die Erde übt eine Gezeitenkraft
auf den Mond aus.
Wenn sich der Mond der Erde nähert,
gibt es einen bestimmten Punkt,
wo die Gezeitenkraft stärker wird
als die Schwerkraft des Mondes.
Die hält ihn zusammen.
Dieser Punkt
wird Roche-Grenze genannt.
Diese Roche-Grenze
liegt zwischen Erde und Mond
bei etwa 15.000 km.
Wenn man
vom Erdmittelpunkt aus misst.
Von der Erdoberfläche aus
bei 9.000 km.
Bewegt sich der Mond
über der Roche-Grenze,
würden die Gezeitenkräfte
ihn regelrecht in Stücke reißen.
Einige dieser Bruchstücke
würden um die Erde kreisen.
Dann hätten wir Ringe,
ähnlich wie der Saturn.
Aber einige Brocken
würden auf der Erde einschlagen.
Schade für den Mond
und schade für uns.
Obwohl es ganz schön aussehen würde.
Wenn es diese Roche-Grenze
um die Erde gibt,
innerhalb der es Objekte
bis Mondgröße zerreißt:
Warum zerreißen
dann nicht Satelliten?
Oder die ISS?
Oder wir?
Die Roche-Grenze
gilt nur für natürliche,
große Himmelskörper.
Wie den Mond.
Körper, die von ihrer eigenen
Schwerkraft zusammengehalten werden.
Unser Körper
oder Satelliten oder die ISS
werden über molekulare Bindungen
zusammengehalten.
Die sind viel stärker.
Wenn der Mond
diese Roche-Grenze überschreitet,
wird er nicht in einzelne Atome
auseinandergerissen.
Sondern in kleinere Brocken.
Wie schwach die Gravitation ist,
im Vergleich zu anderen
physikalischen Wechselwirkungen:
Das haben wir schon mal besprochen.
Wie das aussieht,
wenn der Mond auf die Erde fällt,
das können wir euch zeigen.
Mit dem Computerspiel
"Universe Sandbox".
Eine wissenschaftlich akkurate
Simulation unseres Sonnensystems.
Wenn wir den Mond abbremsen,
von 1.000 m pro Sekunde auf 200,
dann verringert sich
seine Fliehkraft.
Und die Schwerkraft der Erde
überwiegt.
Die kreisförmige Bahn,
auf der sich der Mond bewegt,
wird immer mehr zur Ellipse.
Wenn wir ihn weit genug abbremsen,
verläuft die Ellipse seitlich
an der Erdoberfläche entlang.
Wir touchieren die Erde nur.
Was dann passiert, ist:
Brocken werden aus dem Mond gerissen,
aber er fliegt größtenteils
in der neuen Umlaufbahn weiter.
Diese Brocken
würden aber auf die Erde fallen
und riesige Flutwellen auslösen.
Eine Überlebenschance besteht
nur in höhergelegenem Gelände.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte man
es vielleicht noch aushalten.
Aber auch da
würde es Mondbrocken regnen.
Was man in der Simulation
nicht gut erkennt:
Je näher der Mond an der Erde ist,
desto stärker
sind die Gezeitenkräfte.
Die Flutwellen werden höher.
Durch die Nähe des Mondes würde
nicht nur das Wasser verformt werden,
sondern auch die Landmassen.
Das Einzige, was daran cool wäre:
Den Mond so nah am Himmel zu sehen.
Das stelle ich mir mondän vor.
Begleitet von Flut,
Zerstörung und Chaos
könnte ich aber darauf verzichten.
Für den Mond ist das nur Fiktion.
Sina hat uns ein Beispiel
für die Macht der Roche-Grenze
in unserem Sonnensystem mitgebracht.
Ein gutes Beispiel.
Vom Jupiter.
Innerhalb der Roche-Grenze
zerbrach vor 30 Jahren ein Komet.
Dieser Komet hieß Shoemaker-Levy 9.
Er hatte eine Größe von etwa 4 km
und ist in 21 Teile zerbrochen.
2 Jahre später
sind diese Bruchstücke
in den Jupiter eingeschlagen.
Genauso wie vorhergesagt.
Der Mond kommt der Erde
nicht zwingend näher
und bricht
explosionsartig auseinander.
Wenn er der Erde so nahe kommt,
nimmt der dabei Geschwindigkeit auf.
Dieses Schnellerwerden beeinflusst
den Prozess des Auseinanderbrechens.
Schlimmer wäre es, wenn der Mond
frontal auf die Erde prallt.
Wir bremsen ihn komplett ab
auf eine Bahngeschwindigkeit von 0.
Er hat
keine elliptische Umlaufbahn mehr.
Durch die Anziehungskraft der Erde
bewegt er sich auf sie zu.
Bei dieser Bewegung
nimmt er Geschwindigkeit auf.
Kurz vor dem Aufprall
hat er wieder 10.000 m pro Sekunde.
Diese kinetische Energie
wird beim Aufprall frei.
Das sehen wir hier.
Alles fängt an zu glühen.
Die Durchschnittstemperatur der Erde
geht hoch auf 2.500°C.
Die vom Mond sogar auf 26.000°C.
Das ist auch nur
die Durchschnittstemperatur.
Manche Bereiche des Mondes
sind noch heißer.
Die schmelzen wahrscheinlich weg.
Auf jeden Fall müssen wir
mit massiven Trümmerteilen rechnen.
Das Szenario erinnert an
die Entstehungsgeschichte des Mondes.
Auch da geht man davon aus,
dass ein großer Himmelskörper
mit der Erde kollidiert ist.
Und aus den Trümmerteilen
hat sich der Mond gebildet.
Mehr dazu in der Info-Box.
Deprimierend daran ist:
Wenn der Mond auf 0 abgebremst wird,
dauert es nur 5 Tage,
bis er auf der Erde ankommt.
Wir hätten keine Zeit,
um eine Raumfähre zu bauen,
um abzuhauen.
Wie sich der Mond
in "Moonfall" bewegt,
kann ich anhand der Trailer
nicht erkennen.
Wir sehen aber,
dass Aliens eine Rolle spielen.
Die können den Mond steuern.
Wenn die Kurs
auf die Erde nehmen wollen,
müssten sie den Mond also abbremsen.
Dafür bräuchten sie
wahnsinnig viel Energie.
Fürs Abbremsen müsst ihr
genauso viel Energie aufwenden,
wie der Mond
an kinetischer Energie mitbringt.
Kinetische Energie ergibt sich aus:
1/2 mal Masse
mal Geschwindigkeit zum Quadrat.
In diese Formel setzen wir
unsere bestehenden Werte ein:
die Mondmasse
und die Geschwindigkeits-Differenz
von vor und nach dem Bremsen.
Daraus ergibt sich
eine benötigte Bremsenergie
von 6,5 Yottawattstunden.
Das ist eine Zahl mit 23 Nullen.
Das ist so viel,
dass wir es uns
kaum vorstellen können.
Zum Vergleich:
Das ist so viel Energie,
wie die Sonne in 1.000 Jahren
auf die Erde abstrahlt.
Oder so viel,
wie die Menschheit in 40 Mio. Jahren
an Energie verbraucht.
Also wirklich mega viel.
Beziehungsweise yotta-viel.
Und das ist nur die Energie,
die wir bräuchten,
um die Erde seitlich zu touchieren.
Im Film sieht es so aus,
als würde der Mond
über die Erde hinwegrollen.
Dafür bräuchten wir
noch viel, viel mehr Bremsenergie.
Hier sind wir im Bereich
des absolut Fantastischen.
Eine Alien-Spezies,
die es hinkriegt,
den Mond
in ein Raumschiff zu verwandeln.
Die haben vielleicht
eine Antriebstechnik,
mit der das klappt.
What is that?
Die Idee von "Moonfall" ist,
dass der Mond
ein Innenleben mit Aliens hat.
Die ist nicht neu.
Sie diente schon 1901 als Stoff
für einen Science-Fiction-Roman.
"Die ersten Menschen auf dem Mond"
von H.G. Wells.
Ein Wissenschaftler
und ein Geschäftsmann
reisen auf den Mond.
Von insektenartigen Bewohnern
werden sie
ins Mond-Innere verschleppt.
Das basiert auf der Theorie,
dass die Erde hohl sein könnte.
Weitere Science-Fiction-Romane
wurden davon inspiriert.
Aber leider auch
diverse Verschwörungstheorien.
In einigen ist der Mond
nicht nur hohl und bewohnt,
sondern ein ganzes Alien-Raumschiff.
Das ist nicht wahr.
Genau darauf
baut Roland Emmerich auf.
Bei ihm ist der Mond
eine "Mega-Struktur".
Kein natürlicher Himmelskörper,
sondern
ein künstlich geschaffenes Bauwerk.
Sind wir tot?
Nein,
wir sind nur im Inneren des Mondes.
Für diese Verschwörungstheorie
gibt es aber
keine wissenschaftlichen Beweise.
Im Gegenteil.
Seismische Messungen von Erdbeben,
Pardon, von Mondbeben,
die zeigen,
dass der Mond nicht hohl ist.
Nehmen wir an,
es gäbe keine Seismographen
und damit keine Messdaten.
Und wir würden vom Mond
nur das Volumen und die Masse kennen.
Dann gäbe es
eine kleine Restmöglichkeit,
dass der Mond hohl ist.
Denn die Gravitation
ist immer gleich.
Egal,
ob er eine gleichmäßige Dichte hat
und gefüllt ist.
Oder ob er hohl ist und sich
die gesamte Masse außen befindet.
Gehen wir davon aus,
der Mond ist nur eine Schale.
Wie eine Weihnachtsbaumkugel.
Und diese Schale
hat eine Dicke von 50 km.
Dann bräuchten wir ein Baumaterial
mit einer Dichte
von 40.000 kg pro Kubikmeter.
Da hätten wir Probleme.
Osmium, das dichteste Element
im Periodensystem,
kommt nicht ran.
Das hat nur 23.000 kg pro Kubikmeter.
Uns würde einfach
das Baumaterial ausgehen.
Ob das von einer Statikerin
abgenommen wird
und ein TÜV-Siegel bekommt?
Keine Ahnung.
Lasst eure Ideen
in den Kommentaren da.
Fassen wir zusammen:
Offensichtlich
hat die Alien-Spezies aus "Moonfall"
einige Probleme zu bewältigen.
Ich bin gespannt, wie diese Sachen
im Film aufgelöst werden.
In der Realität steht fest:
Der Mond ist da, wo er sein soll.
Er bewegt sich eher weg
als auf uns zu.
Wie die Erde hat er eine Kruste,
einen Mantel und einen Kern.
Und ist definitiv nicht hohl.
Trotzdem freue ich mich darauf,
mir den Film anzuschauen.
Denn die Bilder sind fantastisch.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Wollt ihr ihn auch sehen?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Gern auch, wie ihr die Folge fandet.
Und schaut mal bei Sina vorbei.
Sie moderiert auf dem Kanal vom DLR
die Reihe "Science at home".
Viele coole Videos.
Den Link packe ich in die Info-Box.
Vergesst nicht,
diesen Kanal zu abonnieren
und die Glocke zu drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Bis dahin!
(mit verstellter Stimme)
Hallo, mein Name ist Roland Emmerich.
Ich mag Videos, in denen es kracht
und Dinge kaputt gehen.
Schaut hier "James Bond"
und hier "Godzilla".
Da geht alles kaputt.
Wir sehen uns bald im Kino.
Kanal abonnieren.
Jetzt!
UT: Copyright MDR 2022